[Music]
do you guys
know what a vulnerable narcissist is
me a vulnerable nurse the [ __ ] does that
mind yeah what does that mean
tell us about you then going against
itself i'm just narcissistic but there's
a difference between grandiose
narcissists and
vulnerable narcissists oh my
i feel like i've learned about over or
covert versus overt narcissism maybe
that's similar
yeah yeah and everyone has a little bit
of narcissism right
i feel like everyone somehow on some
sort of level
is always concerned about themselves and
i think that's just part of being human
that's part of the story
trying to stay alive yeah yeah but i
think once it becomes like a personality
disorder
is because it like it gets out of hand
maybe um
i don't steal anything huh
nobody accused you all right why did you
scour himself
what did you steal nothing so
the way they describe this here is that
vulnerable narcissists
tend to see the world as a competitive
threatening place in which their skills
and abilities go
unrecognized the spark they are the
dermatologist man
yep but what skills is that putting
lotion on
yeah doing it four times a day oh and
you took it personally
competing with it competing with nothing
you vulnerable narcissistic
vegan for sure bart
i think we're going to debunk this
you'll see really all right so they're
saying here that vulnerable narcissists
often adopt a victim mentality
which is disempowering and demotivating
so if people are raised in ways which
increase their likelihood of becoming
narcissists their underlining
personality may dictate whether they're
more likely to become grandiose
or vulnerable narcissists so people
who become vulnerable narcissists they
may be quieter more sensitive
and more introverted and if the
parenting mix is right
these traits may be susceptible to
vulnerable narcissism honestly reading
this [ __ ] i'm like oh my god i think
this is me
i'm like isn't it about you i'm like
cool the article's just written
it's written by two it's written all
about it this author
must have written about you she's
talking she knows me totally also my
hands smell like pennies
pennies this is all about nikki now
it's your stripes such a specific smell
i know i'm like
did you touch blood i don't know well
maybe
i don't know bart doesn't [ __ ] about
things though he doesn't okay once he
said that part out barber's out wait oh
he does
what i don't make myself the victim no
you never do no you're not that's not
you at all well
what we're really focusing on this angle
of this article here
is are you raising your child to be
a vulnerable narcissist oh yeah oh yeah
teach me i don't want that
so first thing on this thing is giving
them a sense of
entitlement and this also goes with your
actions
as the example you might not absolutely
correctly
influencing your kid to be this way but
by your own actions
so they're saying that um instilling in
a
sense of entitlement isn't necessarily
about sitting your child down and
telling them that they deserve
special treatment but they can learn by
your actions when you act entitled
towards other people so for instance
demanding special treatment based on
your perceived importance or financial
status
you are then teaching your child your
children that some people
including them are deserving of special
attention
so um they're also saying that like
bringing your child up to feel confident
about their abilities and making
themselves
in general and to pursue activities and
interests which make them feel good is
healthy and a small dose of entitlement
which
help people think creatively so that's
good
it's good to encourage confidence in
your child but it's very different when
you're teaching them
that they are superior to other people
based
on like their ethnicity their social
class their wealth their intelligence
so growing up that particular way can be
demotivating
oh yeah we tell taika he's dumb and he
sucks at everything he's the worst [ __ ]
that's that that's good
good good job yeah cool now he's dumb
and he sucks since he's chinese and
mexican he is double worse
we push him down extra hard i have a
family member like this
with my cousins and they like she would
always
have to talk about money all the time
and like how much
the outfits that she bought her kids
cost and then she would ask my mom like
how much did hers cost oh yeah like that
and or like if someone was like oh i
like your i like this
um decoration she'd be like thank you it
was from nordstrom it was 400
jesus christ how to put a price tag on
everything
and it had to be like yeah i spent that
much money because i can
like that kind of thing dude for me i
feel like this was instilled in my
childhood because um it was always
really brought up in like in my
attention
like the fact that i uh come from a
broken home that my parents
were divorced like that was part of my
identity and it was always brought up
and um it was also because of
the fact that like we just didn't have a
lot of money and then that was also like
i could never ask for anything you are
poor you're not
special like or you are special because
you're poor or whatever it's like
it's like twisted really weird wow i
feel like that's
kind of like where if i see myself in
this article i feel like that's probably
why that's typo that you recognize that
i mean if that's true yeah so
next one i feel like i talk about money
when i got a deal like if someone's like
oh i like your earrings i'm like oh it's
two dollars
[ __ ] two dollars your intent is
different too though
yeah go get them because yeah the
intense more like communal like
oh [ __ ] you like it let me help you
whereas the other one's like i'm above
you and this is how
you never have this yet i want them to
feel like [ __ ] how much did you pay for
it
because you're dumb as [ __ ] that's why i
get the deal
all right good for you don't ever change
rejection of authority
so narcissists think that they know
better than everyone else and
even when there is no evidence to
support this so then like when a parent
for example is telling their children
that their teachers are all idiots and
they don't know anything
you're like as a parent you're teaching
your child to not respect authority oh
child is going to be [ __ ] up i don't
relate to actually we do not respect
authority
no no my mind was different i respect
yeah
my mom was would go to parent teacher
conference meetings and go
okay tell me what my son did so i know
you can't hit him
because you're american but whatever you
want to hit however you wanted to hit my
son last quarter i'll do it for you
i mean if they earned my respect i'm
like you have governing
prop you could you can govern my
children but i feel like
you know just title alone doesn't earn
respect and so
i like i have a hard time believing
anyone's better than anyone else just
because
of a title yeah yeah okay
next one is acting like a victim
so i mean that's kind of pretty
self-explanatory there
like when you act as if you are living
in an unfair society
and you have zero control over the
things that have happened to you
you are just the victim of being a
victim
which definitely was my [ __ ]
childhood right there
to the teeth so um yeah it's just like
it's just the fact that you're blaming
other people in society or
or other people or society in general
for the things that happen to you so
you're pretty much telling
your child that they lack agency over
their own
lives that's too much that's one thing i
really
raising your kid that's a truck yeah
nobody tells you what to do man they
just hand you the baby like oh
this what was your last see you later i
got more training to put burgers in the
back of a burger king
broiler than to freaking be a father
like some people have a college fund i
might have a therapy fund like you need
no compliments whatsoever i'm gonna try
and i will be
extra hard on that little [ __ ] if they
deserve compliments
then they'll get them it's conditional
love that's oh which traditional one
yeah the next one is it really so the
next one says
making your child feel undeserving of
your love
so it's literally being like i do too
much
like you will only get love if you
achieve something considerably valuable
see i feel like that's how
we were raised yeah i would never do
that to my child
i do over love i need so much love i'm
just like here i'm gonna give you what i
didn't pouring out of you like
my mom never hugged me that's literally
me with
my son too i i do that to my kids my
kids
like yeah i was like stop it time out i
need to
get up sudden yesterday i was like oh
good morning can i have a hug and he's
like swipe right
swipe right what he really did that was
my youngest one that wasn't even the
cringe son
oh and i was like it's swipe left anyway
you don't know how i fit there
you don't even know what swipe it is
they're so normal though
like it just sounds like such a normal
such a jerk
move man kids sound like what a 45 year
old like hollywood screenwriter would
write dialogue for kids
yeah yo no lie the other night same son
it was like 904 right and i hear his
phone you know the facetime sound and he
you can hear him he's like hello he's
like fortnight
at this time of night no are you crazy
it's almost my bedtime and then he hangs
up the phone
i'm responsible and he goes to bed at 9
30.
and he's a young old man
he's like oh no it's past nine i can't
like he has no school
nothing to do that's crazy he's like how
dare you come here
he wakes up between 5 30 and 6.
to do what to just get up he goes makes
breakfast
he has a routine he's a whole routine he
brews the coffee for everyone
he circles the classifieds he literally
goes down there
eats a bowl of cereal hangs out takes a
shower he's up
and i get up at 6 30. he's been up for
an hour i get why you want to smother
him with kids oh he's the best
he's wearing that suit he's got a
briefcase
he's like morning going to banana banana
he really and he's always been like that
always went to bed on his own
never have to put him to sleep always
wake up for school no alarm
well how did you do it you had no manual
you're better at burgers yeah
i didn't do anything i just noticed one
day like you're being
just he just it's me because i go to bed
at 9 30. we both go to bed
we're like i'm tired that's all it is my
older son trash
12 o'clock at night wakes up at 10 11.
he's just freaking
doing nothing we want him to do he
doesn't come out of his room you blame
it on your wife you go like
that's from you oh yeah that's all we do
is parents blame the bad stuff on the
other side of the family
that's true i'm like hey look at your
son
but then if he does something awesome my
son is tired that's all we get that's
all we do
dude in our household it's easy yeah
[Laughter]
that's funny but anyway last one here is
criticizing your child's core
personality oh
yeah so they're saying that um
there might be things as a parent well
this is how you create vulnerable
narcissists
yes if you do these things yes okay yeah
and so they're saying like as a parent
sometimes
you might feel of the way they write it
that your child
um has certain things about
the child that are unacceptable such as
tendencies towards being quiet or more
introverted
or whatever and maybe your child is the
opposite of you and you find that really
hard to accept
or your child is very similar to you and
driven by feelings of self-dislike you
push them to be different
and so you end up raising your child to
feel ashamed of their core self
and so that combined with creating them
and like creating a need in them for
external validation
you are creating the perfect situation
for them to feel judged and suspicious
of the motives of others and then
combined with the sense of being
superior
to other people that's when uh you're
pretty much creating a vulnerable
narcissist
who will then lead a lonely and
resentment if you would have you
so like we all have some of these traits
but you have to have all of the traits
to become a vulnerable narcissist
it's like villain training i feel like
you get i feel like
maybe that's how we all ended up in the
entertainment industry because
we all have some sort of this like some
of those are true like the last two i
was like dang i was definitely raised
the last two
but the other ones i'm like no i
definitely had the last one
i didn't have the the deserving of your
loved one i just
i just never even got it period because
like this one is like
you have to earn it but i'm like even
when i
did good things
but like that's why that's why i saw
myself a lot in this
world that's actually really hard though
apparently that's hard you have a
predetermined
idea of what you want your kids to be
yeah but parenthood is really just like
helping them navigate who they need
it's hard though because it's like
you're dealing with your own [ __ ] yeah
you're oblivious to that because it's
like i gotta stay keep scheduled or i
have
this [ __ ] this deadline or i gotta take
you here or you're
you should be on track and it's it's i
can see how you and like
get overwhelmed as a parent i they're
trying to save you from yourself like
because
the last one was like oh if they're too
similar to your personality type then
you
you like dislike that in yourself i
think that was like how my
my dad was when like he was a crybaby
growing up and he get picked on for it
so i cried and he would like get really
mad at me for crying because he's like
you can't cry like that
and they're gonna beat you up yeah yeah
i'm a girl
it sounds okay for me
[Music]
do